[Applause]
Nobel laureates excellencies ladies and
gentlemen it's a great pleasure and
privilege for me to welcome all of you
to Karolinska Institutet a la medical we
are welcoming you for the 2018 Nobel
lectures in Physiology or medicine
my name is Olli ultrason and I'm the
president of Karolinska Institutet
during a noble week and particularly
through the Nobel lectures we celebrate
science and rejoice at unique
contributions of some exceptional
individuals research is a way a
quenching of a thirst for knowledge
testing our own limits and having an
outlet for our creativity and
competitive spirit within Physiology or
medicine the ultimate goal is to achieve
scientific breakthroughs that change our
views of human health disease and normal
life processes
DLO rates to your seminal discoveries
you have indeed made historic
contributions to these very areas today
it's an honor for me to extend my
warmest welcome on behalf of Karolinska
Institute to Jim Allison and tasuku
Hanzo the 2018 Nobel laureates in
Physiology or medicine on Monday they
will receive the Nobel Prize for the
discovery of cancer therapy by
inhibition of negative immune regulation
without further ado I now call upon
Edward Smith professor of molecular
genetics and member of the Nobel
Committee for Physiology or medicine
professor Smith will now introduce the
laureates please the floor is yours
so thank you this year's laureate Jim
Allison was born in the small South
Texas town of Alice in 1948 from an
early age he was drawn to science he
played with his chemistry Sept and was
fascinated by dissecting frogs his
father was a doctor in the town Jim
Allison sometimes accompanied him on
house course but when doing that he
realized that following in his father's
footsteps wasn't exactly what he wanted
during high school he ran into teacher
would not teach evolution Allison took
this very very seriously to him biology
without Darwin was like physics without
Newton he therefore refused to take the
class and this put him in danger of
actually failing high school fortunately
a compromise was reached he fulfilled
the requirements by taking college
biology by correspondence with
University of Texas where he later also
received bachelor's and PhD in
biochemistry as an immunologist dr.
James Allison's fundamental discoveries
in parallel with others include defining
the structure of the t-cell antigen
receptor demonstrating that cd28
provides co-stimulatory signals
necessary for full t cell activation and
showing that ctla4 is an inhibitory
checkpoint which impedes activation of
t-cells all of this was basic research
and based on his basic research Allison
was the first to propose and demonstrate
that immune checkpoint blockade might be
a powerful strategy to treat tumors as
we will hear more about he was also
involved in the development of he
believed I'm up a monoclonal antibody
which was approved by FDA for treatment
of metastatic melanoma seven years ago
dr. Allison is a member of the National
Sciences and the National Academy of
Medicine he has received numerous awards
including the Lifetime Achievement Award
from the American Association of
immunologists the law jay old award the
Novartis award in clinical immunology
the Medal of Honor in basic research
from the American Cancer Society the
Harvey Prize in human health the
breakthrough prize in Biosciences the
Wolf Prize and in 2015 the Lasky DeBakey
clinical medical research award now if
he hadn't been and become a scientist
Jim Allison may well have become a
musician he has played the harmonica at
least casually since his youth he told
me that he became more serious in
playing the harmonica during his
postdoctoral years in California and
this culminated with playing on stage
with Willie Nelson at the Stingaree bar
by the sea in downtown San Diego now
that wouldn't be Allison's last run-in
with Willie Nelson and his band it so
happened that Nelson's longtime
harmonica player Mickey Raphael read
about Allison's research in the
newspaper and he then invited him to
come and play with the band so in 2016
in what he calls one of the five best
moments in his life Allison and Raphael
traded harmonica solos onstage with
Willie Nelson and they remain friends to
this day
please welcome this year's laureate
G Madison
[Music]
Thank You dr. Smith and mr. president
and members of the selection committee
and members of the Nobel assembly I'm
really honored to have the opportunity
to speak to you all noted guests here
and give you some insights into what
we've been doing and why I've been doing
it for the last several years I'd like
to dedicate this this talk to the many
students and fellows that have trained
with me and really done the work that
I'm going to be talking about over the
years and also to the doctors and the
patients that were involved it had no
small risk to themselves in the early
clinical trials and finally to my
partner in life and science dr. Pat
Manish Sharma with whom much of the work
I was doing I'm gonna show you is done
in collaboration where's the and so the
people tried to list some of these
people of course they aren't all up
there but the people whose names are in
red or people are contributed
specifically to the new work I'm going
to show you later today and what I want
to try to do is show you the early stuff
that we did leading up to the idea of
checkpoint blockade show you where
that's at and then finished with some
mechanistic studies that have provided
some surprising new insight and how this
actually occurs so why would you want to
use immunotherapy to treat cancer well I
think we all know now that the cancers
of the ZZZ of many diverse gene
mutations ultimately that sees the tumor
cells become highly and unstable with
respective genomic integrity and so it
really can be viewed as many different
cancers each independent of histo type
each which are caused by distinct
genetic mechanisms but one of the things
we've learned since the war on cancer
started is that trying to target the
single causative mutations with targeted
small molecules always essentially leads
to relapse after response and that's
because there's so many mutations by the
time you target one there's already a
resistant mechanism which the tumor can
use to have to selection to bypass it
but t-cells which has been I love ever
since I heard about them and graduate
school offer three things that really
other kinds of cancer treatment do not
and the first one is specificity I think
that everybody knows that t-cell
recognized peptides on the surface of
the cells presented by you may see
molecules that tell the immune system
what's going on in them and we know now
from worker Bob Schreiber and many
others that in the case of t-cells
they're focused on the mutations
products of the mutations that occur in
the tumor cell not just the ones that
cause it which is what targeted
therapies do but pretty much any of them
so you could get poly valency by
targeting these because the immune
system doesn't know what the mutations
are doesn't know whether they're caused
it or not it doesn't matter they just
tell them you system something's
different the second thing is what
you've got t-cells a number of them
become slowly renewing memory cells and
so they're there for the rest of your
life basically and can be reawakened if
necessary to come after the tumor again
and finally the immune system is very
adaptable
you've probably got 50 to 70 million
different T cells circulating around
which in that cost that can change with
time since the immune system is
generating new and still immune system
can adapt spontaneously the changes in
the tumor and so it's easily a match to
cancer which is the whole theme of this
talk so I'm just going to condense a lot
of work here to get about it on the same
page and in 1982 we worked out the
structure of the antigen receptor
heterodimer but with antibodies a number
of labs showed after that that soon
after that that signaling through the
t-cell receptor by itself is not
sufficient to activate t-cells you need
an additional co stimulatory signals who
were provided only by very specialized
cells such as dendritic cells in 1988 we
showed that that receptor for those
signals was a molecule called cd28
and others show that there were ligands
farter b7 but there was an awesome also
a molecule called ctla-4 which had an
unknown function it was only known that
it did not was not expressed until after
t saw
mission so the current view is waiting
the t-cell gets a t-cell receptor signal
and a cd28 co stimulatory signal you
turn on two pathways to two programs
shown in green there are a lot of genes
that associated whose products were
associated with cell proliferation
because you have to expand a few dozen
cells of any particular type to hundreds
of thousands of cells very quickly to
get the soldiers in the field to attack
the cancer but you also started this
wasn't really realized until about 1994
you also start an off program by
induction of the program induced by seek
like for expression which eventually
accumulates in a Cell and can turn
t-cells off so without going through all
the work one of the things that we had
shown in the meantime is that tumor
cells lining Mouse tumor cells have
plenty of antigens and we showed that
because we put b7 molecules into them so
that they can provide co-stimulation
they'll immediately get rejected but
normally they're not rejected because
they're invisible to the immune system
not because they lack antigens because
they can't give the second signal and so
I reasoned at the time that and you
can't start at a B response until tumor
cells die and they specialized to the
energetic cells come in pick up the bits
of dying tumors redisplay the antigens
on their surface in the context of b7 so
this cross priming then initiates an
immune response against ISA against
tumor cells and but then secretly four
of course is the normal process is
induced and so it's a kind of race the
older tumors had a head start and if the
tumor gets to such a mass as the T cells
can't generate enough to take care of it
we thought then the tumor wins because
of the they would be turned off by seats
left for so we had the idea of just
disabling the brakes by putting in an
antibody to see to look for a very
simple process and just keeping the
brakes on alerting the T cells keeps
running well we did this well anyway
what that's shown on this cartoon in the
right and there's there's a couple of
features there that are that are very
interesting when I first thought of this
one is that we're not retargeting the
immune system not the tumor cells so the
kind of cancer doesn't make any
difference
it shouldn't make any difference because
you know all tumors have neo antigens
and that really doesn't matter what kind
of cancer say we don't have to make a
new drug for every cancer cell it's a
universal therapy that could be
potentially used for any kind of cancer
and the second one is since it started
by cross priming you can take advantage
of that priming by death to use in
combination with chemotherapy radiation
hormone therapy whatever kills some
tumor cells and give agents that do
those things properties of the immune
therapy as well and so there we go sorry
and so the idea of course is wonderful
idea but does it work and so this just
shows what the first experiments we did
we've got transplantable tumors growing
in the backs of mice you see untreated
they grow after euthanize the mice block
cd28 they're go faster but if we inject
antibodies to seek life for the tumor
grows for a while then gets rejected and
so when we got this result I was I was
amazed not expected to slow the tumor
but it just completely eliminated I'm
covering up this one molecule out of
everything that's going on was
sufficient to give tumor rejection so
just to make a long story very short
after two years delay because people in
part couldn't understand how you could
treat cancer by ignoring the cancer cell
and treating the immune system we worked
with the company called meta racks and
Maeda
and he had a human seats left for
antibody called
epi looma map and this is a patient at a
phase 1 trial started about 2000 this is
in May 2001 actually what she started
you can see these big tumors in her
lungs she had metastatic melanoma that
failed every therapy including high-dose
aisle 2 and a dendritic cell vaccine she
got one injection of three MiG's per kig
of secretly four and I happened to visit
Tony Rivas her doctor in 2011 10 years
got an injection the cat-scan on the
right is from her tenth year checkup
after again that a single injection and
she's actually still doing fine she's
almost nineteen years out now for
metastatic melanoma and I should point
out that when we started this work the
median life expectancy after diagnosis
with with metastatic melanoma was 11
months so it was essentially a death
sentence and there was no drug that had
ever prolonged life at any level
whatsoever so there are a lot of trials
done resulting in a phase 3 registration
trial with overall survival is the
endpoint which took almost four and a
half years to complete and what you can
see here because this is the if you live
line this one this is the placebo
control here and what you can see is
removed the survival over about four
months which would have been sufficient
for FDA approval because no drug had
ever done that before but as you can see
here very interesting thing happens
between two and three years if the
survival curve flattens out and stayed
that way for the duration of the trial
which means basically nobody is dying of
the disease after about three years and
so at my 2015 there was follow-up data
of several thousand patients what you
can see here is it's the same at three
years and kind of flattens out stays
that way for ten years and about twenty
little over twenty percent of the
patients so I think for all intents and
purposes for this disease people that
make it past four years I really think
you can consider them to be cured and
they don't have to worry about you know
what's gonna go on I wouldn't say that
lightly and it's nice to get on several
thousand patients with this just
follow-up therapy but the question is
why isn't it a hundred percent you know
why isn't just a fraction there's a
number of mechanistic reasons why that
might be true but of course there's
another possibility that there were
other checkpoints and and dr. Hangzhou
had discovered a molecule called PD one
and by about 2001 it was shell that
there was another checkpoint actually
and it differs in a couple of important
ways one of them is that one of its
ligands could actually be expressed on
the surface of tumors
an induced by gamma interferon made by
the cd8 cell what that means is then
that rather than working at priming like
seek like for it's working on fully
differentiated cells at the end of their
development and turning off the
functional cells by interaction or CPD
Awadh on the tumor cell with PT one on
the T cell and I'll come back to that in
detail in a while anyway there is very
quickly this went to clinical trials
this is a summary of a phase one trial
devices and apollyon very good results
of melanoma announcement small cell lung
cancer renal cancer no responses in
colorectal cancer although later on Bert
vogelstein shows there's a subset that
as genomic instability that has
microsatellite instability defects and
DNA damage repair this subset has a
large number of mutations and patients
with that defect do respond and then
there's also no responses to castrate
resistant prostate cancer and I'll show
you later that we I think figured out
why that is and you know way around it
so where do we go well obviously
combinations you got two different drugs
that work at different stages of t-cell
development and so put them together so
this is a trial when if several really
put together by Jed wallchuck and others
this is the IPPY loom AB only arm and
you can see here the
and I PT well then they will vote you
man bad about it here plus and I seeked
like for there's a 60% response right
now when you combine those two
functionally different checkpoints and
the last time I checked the survival is
out to about four years on these
patients so we're getting close to the
point of knowing whether this is going
to be as durable as if you do them
abalone and there's no reason to think
that it won't be and so I think we've
gone here so this remarkably from a
almost uniformly fatal disease to being
able to get meaningful responses that
last perhaps for decades as well with
this combination and 60% of melanomas
and so that's the best response thing
and a lot of people say well this is
just a melanoma drug that's not really
true
various trials have been done the FDA's
approved these edges for non-small-cell
lung cancer for renal cell cancer
Hodgkin's lymphoma bladder cancer head
and neck Merkel cell which is a very
even more lethal form of skin cancer
also
gastric cancer in a pallet cellular
carcinoma and I'll come back to this
this is really a remarkable approval so
any tumor of any histo type that has
defects and DNA damage repair and
consequently has high low levels of neo
antigens can be treated regardless of
what kind of cancer they are for that
the first time that's ever been approval
for a particular genetic defect and in a
class of tumors and so we're in a pretty
good setting we know a lot of tumors
respond not all and not all of them is
high a fraction as we would like so to
go forward really in a rational way we
need to know the cellular mechanism
molecular mechanisms of the effects so
that we can you know design the best way
to combine things and develop strategies
for identifying patients who are going
to respond and so at MD Anderson dr.
Sharma and I built on some work that she
bit on for some time and genital urinary
cancers to develop what we call the the
immunotherapy platform and the goal of
this is to do mechanistic studies on any
patient with any kind of cancer and all
this being treated with any drug that
would have impact an immune system of
course we defined that as anything
basically and the idea is to get tissue
and blood from them and analyze it by
all the techniques that we can to get
some insight into what's going on and
I'm going to go through the details but
so far we've got enrolled over 3,000
patients have gotten matched samples of
tissue and blood from those patients and
so I'll just show you one brief thing
about what how we've used this to study
what's going on in prostate cancer so as
I told you there were no responses in
phase one with with PD one with with
early trials of Appeal aluminum there
were
there's a small number but remarkable
responses of men whose PSA was
undetectable and had metastasis
disappear and symptomatic relief nothing
so this went to a phase 3 trial shown
here which unfortunately failed there
was no real significant difference
between the it people who may have only
you know treatment and the placebo
control and so we wanted to find out
what that was so using dr. Sharma's
approach this which is to do with
localized as treatment with localized
cancers let's go to pre-surgical trial
where the patients are given a couple of
doses of this case if you live a man
before they go to surgery and so these
were guys that were given two doses
before they went prostatectomy and so at
the time of surgery we get the whole
organ you know - what the pathologist
needs for diagnosis we got the whole
organ and for studies and we can pretty
much do anything we want from flow
cytometry to multiplex tissue sections
RNA expression genomic sequence is such
a really powerful technique to get data
and so this is what we found on the left
column here these are mr. chemicals I
mean just a chemical slides what you can
see here is before treatment no cd4 is
virtually no CDH very few regulatory
t-cells or if you memory cells etc but
after two doses of Appeal ooh in lab it
goes from and I'm not sure the
comparative size but this looks a lot
like pancreatic cancer at baseline where
after treatment you can see robust
infiltration with cd4 cd8 fox B 3 T reg
cells these cells just get this
activated killer cells here and
macrophages so this now becomes to look
like melanoma and so just to show you
what happens though so secretly four
drives the T cells into a cold tumor but
it also induces all these inhibitory
Marcus as you can see here with pto PDL
one Vista PD one and lagg-3 so all of
those are inhibitory molecules that were
induced by a pollutant lab treatment so
you can see the numbers of cells or you
see the cells here with PD 1 PDL 1 and
vista so these are two very different
the inhibitory molecules and when you
look at the numbers you can see the PDL
one is induced on the cd8 t-cells
themselves as well as on macrophages and
the tumor cells whereas Vista is induced
to a little bit on cd8 cells but mostly
on macrophages in other studies that I
want to show you we know that PDL one
and Vista are always expressed by
different subsets of macrophages they
aren't ever found on the on the same
cell and so this then led to propose
something obvious about the at this time
back mr. Barr squibbitt shut down their
entire prostate program because you know
pd-1 didn't do anything and then acetyl
afore did it occasionally but not enough
to be considered significant so we went
to them and showed you showed in those
data so we need to give it mipi to drive
the t-cells in and then in a pd-1 or
pd-1 logon to cover up those that
inhibitory pathway that was induced by
AP liver may have and so what you can
see here is one of the patients these
are PSA levels his PSA levels have been
rising for some time hitting almost 500
when he got the first dose of anesthesia
for a month later the second dose month
later the third dose by then it was
essentially at baseline and a fourth
doors here anyway the patient's
metastases completely disappeared and it
was a complete responder symptomatic
relief and everything so there were a
few of these in the trial so with some
fiddling with the dose it was a little
bit toxic at the way that was done it's
being reopened with a few hundred
patients and hoping will
registration for the treatment of
castrate-resistant prostate cancer and
so rested talking about I really talk
about the differences between these two
there's a tendency to say you know we've
got two checkpoints and one of the
things that people figured out right
away is that is that PT one has fewer
adverse events then and seek late for
blockade and so let's just use PD one
but point I want to make here is that
these are very different drugs it's not
just that they're but checkpoints and
you don't have to think about as I told
you see player four is hardwired it's
part of every immune response that your
body makes whereas PT one is induced
resistance by gamma interferon most the
time inducing PDL one
it's also been shown to play a role in
other settings and the protection of the
developing embryo from maternal attack
on fetal antigen so we think that this
is a protective mechanism it's just
co-opted by cancer cells to protect them
from the same mechanism as I showed you
or the cartoon shows the c-54 works
mainly during priming pd-1 on exhausted
cells
ctla4 i'm not going to show you the data
but it's been shown in several settings
to recruit new t-cells and expand clonal
diversity whereas pd-1 doesn't seem to
do that it could expand the clones that
are already there and number but doesn't
allow recruitment of new clones so I'll
show you secretly for primarily affects
cd4 cells whereas PD one only he
actually only affects cd8 cells as I
showed you just below maps each life or
could drive T cells into Cole tumors PT
one doesn't responses again because it
works at priming to an acetyl for often
very slow where there's rapid too
pd-1 which you might expect since that's
just you're reactivating already
differentiated cells I mentioned the
adverse events and one of the things
becoming apparent that disease
recurrence after response with seek late
for very rare in melanoma at least
they'll usually focal and then she could
be dealt with my surgery you know
whereas disease recurrence after
responses with pd-1 are pretty
significant is about fifteen percent or
so in melanoma and twenty five percent
in in lung cancer
resistance mechanism include loss of
gamete a fair amount of sensitivity and
other things so in order to just sort of
get a really unbiased way and although
it's biased that were just looking at
t-cells here and what plays a role in
the response we use site off time of
flight cytometry where I'm not gonna go
through I'm sure everybody's heard about
but he uses antibodies coupled to heavy
metal ions that can be distinguished
very sharply you know mass spec and so
you can do up to forty three parameters
and so what we did was to use one for
live dead a few for looking at dividing
cells and then a few for bar coding
because we mix everything and analyze it
together and then D convoluted but many
group things by a tizzy plot called by
just putting things which look more like
the cells in the grouping here and then
we can identify what those are by
different markers and then we measure
different clusters of the frequency of
the cells in different clusters and then
we keep track for every mouse that we
look at we keep track of the size of the
tumor when it was harvested and then we
can relate any particular changes that
we see with the ones that the changes
that are important to the size of the
tumor and so the way that experiments
done is that we give mice to MERS give
them antibody different intervals and
then take thirteen in the case of M
Caesar
we harvested look at the tissues and I'm
going to show you just data on MC 38
which is a fairly high mutation load
immuno genic tumor the response to both
these agents by themselves and but we
also got the same results using a team
are called B 16 B l6 which is very low
in mutational load it's not affected by
mono therapies with these antibodies so
we have to use a vaccine with it but the
results are the same with both of them
so this is what the the MC 38 tumor
looks like when you gate on lymphocytes
and then our bone marrow drive cells and
then t-cells ourselves Express cd3 EPS
loss and so here the it's just dot plots
basically representing you know each dot
represent your cell blue as mice that
got control antibodies red is honest to
God and I see too late for it green is -
they got PD one and so what you can see
here is that is that there's a real
positive of well actually let me start
down here if you look here with NKT
cells in Gamma Delta cells is
essentially random there's nothing going
on they're just equally mixed but what
you can see here is there's a real pal
city of red dots compared to blue or
green and amongst the T rags so this is
something that actually was first
noticed by surge of cassava and Tyler
Simpson in my lab as well as by Alan
Corman's lab several years ago and that
in the mouse the an acetyl aid for
antibody can deplete regulatory C cells
T cells because they expressed so much
seek life for by mechanism involving
macrophages mediating antibody dependent
cytotoxicity so that's that and there's
controversy as to whether this happens
and humans are not we don't think it is
and I'll show you some data you know
well but then here are the cd4 effector
cells this is all TC for cells except
the ones to have Fox p3 and you can see
here there's an over-representation of
red dots so these cells are being
expanded by seats like for when you get
to the cd8 area here you can see that
overall there seems to be a big increase
with pd one but there are patches where
secretly four is expanding cells and so
this is overall what's going on but what
you can do of course is do a fina graph
where you line up each cluster with all
the marker genes that they express so we
had all the marker genes from the major
cell surface antigens and
differentiation transcription factors in
this panel and so just to make this
approachable or visible here we divided
by cell time again no difference of the
NKT cells T regs there's two kinds
there's one kind that they all have Fox
p3 one has a maturation antigen called
KLR g1 those cells and the smaller
population that are Caylor g1 negative
you see here look like they're depleted
by C too late for treatment if you look
at the cd4 effector cells there's
there's really two major populations
there's these cells that I'm going to
talk a lot about these cells from the
rest of the lecture
these cells are th1 like would call them
th one like because they have t-bet and
so they make a lot of get'em interferon
and TNF alpha but they also have AI
costs which is makes them a little bit
strange and I'll come back to what this
is a little bit later but those cells
are very strongly associated with
decrease in tumor size whereas this
other population which do it just looks
like an activated T so don't really do
anything
and then I activate a cd4 they don't
really do anything with PD one what you
see is a preference for
preferential increase and a subset of
cd8 cells that have high PD one hi Tim
three you're also high lag three so
these are what we call exhausted they're
terminally differentiated but they're
also functionally exhausted they do not
divide left themselves but they're
dividing here when you give a
deceitfully and a PD one they start
dividing and these are also very
strongly associated with smaller tumor
size but what is obvious from from these
data is that despite the fact that
they've been treated with that a PD one
antibody they're still expressing PD one
so if the antibody goes away these cells
are going to stop dividing again we
haven't changed the phenotype at all and
this is also supported by some work from
John wary who's shown there's epigenetic
changes in the PD one gene that lock it
on in these cells you can't do anything
about that and those are not increased
significantly by CSA for treatment then
there are cells here that or PD one
intermediate they also are terminally
differentiated and if they express the
Omi's and civil other markers but
they're they're not exhausted and you
can see these are expanded by both seek
to lay four and pd1 those also are
strongly associated with decrease in
tumor size and then there's these cells
which look like naive t-cells again and
these cells which are they're expanded
by CTA for as well then these cells
which look like recently activated
t-cells and and they're actually
associated with bigger tumor size so
these are getting in the way of the
responses so we've really got three
populations one cd4 which is expanded
just by seats left for one seat cd8
which is expanded just by PD one and
then this group which expanded by both
that associated that those are the cells
that are playing the main role in
shrinkage of tumor cells and so it's
just sort of summarizes that the
mechanist is very you know are different
and that may be why when you put these
two things together
everything works it works much better
we're working on that now and have some
data in review but measuring these
subtypes is a lot more informative than
just measuring total cd4s and CD aids
it's a telling who's going to respond
and the other thing is that the
therapeutic details didn't really matter
in this experiment and so does this
happen in humans well this is not
obviously as easy to do as it is it - we
could only find because the standard of
care now is both antibodies we can only
find one patient that was treated with
just out of PD Watt and a few that were
treated just with and I fell asleep late
for and only a small group that were
been treated with and a PD wand and so
this just shows the same roof and the
point is that essentially the same is
the group was expanded largely about PD
1 and these are these exhausted CD aids
and then the CD 4i cost positive side
gets expanded again by C 24 we can see
here mono therapy and there also by
combination therapy you can see here t
rags are not depleted by they don't have
to see to look for the other thing I
want to point out is that the only
control that we had here with normal
donor PBMC and I just want to point out
that there are none of these cells the
ones that are effective with with this
each leg for we can't find those using
this panel of antibiotics we cannot find
them in the normal blood and so I come
back to that in a little while I think
that's that's very significant because
it suggests that co-stimulation may have
something to do with the regulation of T
cell differentiation and so I'm going to
show you the evidence last less next
lesson if I'll talk about so just for
those non immunologist there's basically
two schools of thought we know that
individual transcription factors are
associated with the differentiation
state of T sub cd4 T cells got a three
for example as
what are called th2 cells that make th
two types saticons t-bet is a
transcription factor that determines
that the TD was the th one fate which
make gamete if you're on a tnf-alpha ror
gamma T since cells down th17 pathway to
make aisle 17 of the things that finally
Fox p3 dick Tama dictates the function
of these cells to be T reg cells so this
was thought as a linear process so
you've got a naive cell it gets
activated by antigen and what it becomes
depends on what's going on in the
environment at that time but several
years ago John O'Shea of the late bill
Paul suggested that it's more of a
nuance process that their intermediates
between cells they could go back and
forth or somewhat expense multiple
transcription factors and so it's been a
lot of support for this but but not a
lot of data so far and so anybody what
we think we're thinking this is this is
done by Spencer way is that one thing
that that that ctla4 does on cells of
course it it can stop the response but
also attenuates the T cell signaling
that negative effects lower it so you
know the real strong antigen you might
get a maximum signal citrate just here
at arbitrary units but if they
attenuated due to high levels of seed
like for expression it's much lower so
if he takes each life far away and they
would have given a signal strength that
it's much higher than you could ever
achieve you know in wild-type max you
get supranatural if you will not
supernatural but super odd night so
levels of t-cell and I try to say these
are magics ability but but you could
just get a much stronger T cell receptor
signal and we've known for several years
now do the work of Kim Bottomly and
others that stronger signals tend to be
associated with th one type cells so we
decided to look just take C 24 away
genetically and go through the same sort
of process
and see what we've got well the green
and blue dots here are wild-type and
heterozygous and the red areas are
secretly for knockouts and what's
apparent by the way these are all seedy
fours with that same thing well not with
same panel but with markers two
different subsets of cd4s what you can
see is there's this group here and then
this one here which are clearly very
different than the cells that are you
see in wild-type mice and so what we
think is that this is represent cells
that this represents differentiate of
space that's prevented by the presence
of seagull at 40 cells in normal mice
never get a chance to go down those
pathways where if you remove seagull at
four they they can and so if you go back
and you look at the kind of cells that
are there yet absent and wild-type in
lymph node and in hetero and you see
these cells these are our friends the I
cost positive TD T bet positive cd4s
these are the same cells you get when
you treat mice or humans with with that
acetylate four it's another population
that's non non non sauce two T cell
intermediate T cell that has this one
actually has T bet and then you see this
one over here as bcl6 got a 3r or gamma
T so has three different transcription
factors that's really a confused cell
it's made well maybe an intermediate on
the way to one of those other other
pathways and so there's another way to
look at these rather than looking at
clusters it's called archetype analysis
where the tumor you start with the T
cell you want with the cell you want and
then measure just going a little bit
further away from it and measure what
what cells are there until you get the
ones that are the farthest away from a
starting point and so that enables you
to to tell the difference between cells
they might have differentiated from
there to there directly
as opposed to you know you could tell if
they follow this pathway you end up with
an archetype here here in here that are
the furthest difference that they can be
from in this case normal t-cell so these
are the extreme cells that are the
farthest away and so when Yuri analyzed
the data about that mathematical time
you see to here that it really here out
these spaces out in this you know seat
plate for - space the two that are most
interesting of cluster five or cluster
seven cluster seven again as the eye
costs positive pd-1 high these are those
CD fours that we find when we treat mice
with anti seats like for these cells are
other really mixed up guys here and
again these are the not shown ever these
are Fox p3 positive so we think then
that this is evidence for the fact that
seek life for is not just expanding and
cells were already there it may be
generating an entirely new cell by
sending it down a differentiation
pathway which is not possible in the
presence of seats like for so this is
something that an interesting thing that
we're working on further to get further
data but I want to come back to these
now because just it's not that these
were unknown I'm just showing you all
that data because that's unbiased it's
just what the machines tell us but these
cells were actually discovered about ten
years ago by Pam Sharma and a
pre-surgical study of bladder cancer
anyway I cos is a member of the seed
cd28 seat life or family as a tree it's
got a single ligand until my casa ligand
normally if you tell an immunologist
i've got an i cost positive cd4 I'll
tell you it's a follicular t helper cell
which makes type 2 cytokines or it's a
regulatory t-cell neither of which would
do you any good in a tumor and so as I
said Pam Shaw my first fountain needs to
be increased in both tumor and blood and
patients after if you live without
treatment and she by shortage so they
said all of the cd4 positive gamma
interferon and TNF alpha cells that
produced
used in response to tumor antigens study
with general shock showed that that
increase was associated with longer
survival and then in mouth studies so
that they were essential for optimum
efficiency of ctla-4 blockade in other
words if you do the therapies that we
had children under conditions were to
get about a 90% response it would drop
to about 50% if you try to advise the
lack neither I costs or its ligand so it
appears to play an important role and it
seems to be by signaling through pi3
kinase to the Akt pathway and now I'll
show you that this this is a really can
be considered positive checkpoint you
could target it to improve efficacy of C
for signaling so this is a study that we
did to explore that where mice are given
tumor and then given anti ctla4 and
along with either irradiated tumor cells
or radiated tumor cells that have been
transduced to express a casa ligand and
these are all the singles antibody
controls this is the response rate that
you get when you have an acetal a 4 plus
the radiated wild-type tumor cells
about 30% but that goes up to close to
90% if you just put a casa ligand on the
tumor cell and if you do that at ICAST
knockout mice you don't see you lose
that effect so this shows indeed that by
giving it a seat to look for and then I
caused agonistic I cost signals you get
a much more powerful cd4 response and a
time to show you data but it's because
of about a 30-fold increase in cells
that make both gamma interferon and TNF
alpha so we formed a company and made an
antibody to this and it's in trials now
we don't know what's gonna happen but at
least the preclinical data is and it's
pretty good so I'm gonna just finish by
saying you could block multiple
checkpoints and I've shown you negative
and positive also there's many things
being explored
you know without lytic viruses a local
ablation to
and has the United immunity blocking
other suppressive factors vaccines are
coming along and finally genetically
targeted therapies in combination with
checkpoints I think that what we're
going to see in the future is that
checkpoint blockade is going to become a
part of essentially all therapies and
might be combined with radiation or
chemo therapies or very many other
things in counts of tumors that don't
respond well to checkpoints by
themselves so as to closed and say this
is what we're looking for go ahead and
and cancer therapy for the last thirty
years or so and that's you treat a large
number of patients and and compare the
median survival to the standard of care
or whatever and if you move it over
about a few months you know that's a
success and that's certainly important
to those patients who respond but we
know now from if you um have that you
can do that but also have a response
rate of 20% or so in melanoma patients
that you know live for a decade after a
single round of treatment and of course
this is not data this is aspirational
but what we hope to do is actually move
that tail of the curve up as high as we
can get it as many counts of cancer as
we can and the good news is I think we
know the basic rules there's still some
frustrations and bill blastoma
pancreatic cancer for example which
haven't responded yet and we need to get
the response rate and the patients who
do respond up to again as close to 100%
as we can and I'm optimistic they will
succeed if we keep going in with that
I'll finish and close thank you very
much for you
[Applause]
so this year's laureates Tosca Hangzhou
was born in Kyoto in 1942 this was
during the World War two so these were
really difficult times the family moved
around quite a lot but Anya managed to
make it through so in the 1960s he
started medicine at the Kyoto University
and became MD in 1990 and 1966 he spent
the next years in the Graduate School in
the same university after that he went
to the US during 1971-72 he was a fellow
at the Carnegie Institution of
Washington in Baltimore and later he
worked at NIH in 1979 he became
professor at Osaka University and
thereafter at the department of medical
chemistry Kyoto University where he
later served as Dean from skier he is
distinguished professor at the Kyoto
University Institute for Advanced Study
and from this year he is also the deputy
director-general when I first met with
the task on Gao many years ago he was
interested in working on cloth switch
recombination in B lymphocytes and
trying to understand the process he also
succeeded in finding the reason and he
identified the new protein this protein
was named activation induced cited in
the amylase and this crucial enzyme was
not only important for switching the
claws but it also causes somatic
hypermutation and this is important to
make antibodies work really well
I also remember listening to a seminar
in the 1990s when he mentioned about PD
one the importance of which was not at
award understood at that time his
discoveries related to PD one originate
from its identification and all the way
through the understanding of its role as
a checkpoint inhibitor and of course
antibodies directed against this
molecule
become highly important cancer drugs
doctor han gyeo has received many awards
and i will mention a few he has received
the imperial price and the Japan Academy
prize he's a foreign associate of the US
National Academy of Sciences and member
of the german academy of natural
scientists in 2012 he received robert
cole price he has received the order of
culture japan the tank rice and in 2016
their Kyoto Prize he has also received
the ko medical science prize and the
Warren Alpert foundation price the score
new likes music and painting he has tell
me that he always tries to visit museums
and go to concerts when traveling he
made an attempt to play the flute but it
didn't really work out so he gave it up
but tasks evangelize essentially all
types of exercise such as tennis
baseball basketball table tennis and
golf
he takes golf quite seriously and his
handicap is 14 he told me yesterday that
he every year he plays a few times with
Shinya Yamanaka Nobel laureate in 2012
when his father was also doctor similar
to Allison's he was a surgeon he was a
good painter and played tennis and golf
very well
similar to Jim Allison there were things
happening during also during Hondros
school period in Honda's case as a child
his teachers did not perceive him as a
good obedient pupil this was because he
often asked very difficult questions
since reading regular textbooks never
really satisfied him one day a young
female teacher even began to cry when he
pointed out that she might be wrong
since then he stopped asking questions
in school and instead he decided to read
books other than textbooks
by himself and of course today we are
the ones that read about Tosca Honda's
discoveries please welcome this year's
laureate Tuscon
[Applause]
Thank You professor it was miss for your
kind introduction
this thing is guests ladies and
gentlemen I'm extremely honored and
humbled to have the opportunity to give
Noble another lecture at the Kerensky
Institute for this I had free appreciate
the enormous efforts of the another
Assembly of the current sky Institute
the title of my talk Serendipity's of
acquired immunity as doer meaning they
represent not only my contribution to
cancer is rather for teachers but also
all human beings
fortunate to have acquired immunity
immunity otherwise can Simon therapy
must have been impossible I was born in
Kyoto in 1942
my family has generated many medical
doctors my surgeon my father was a
surgeon and had a rather strict educator
on the other hand my mother is so
beautiful and always warm-hearted she
has been the my guardian goddess until
she passed away five five years the
first incidence when I was charmed by a
natural science
took place at the playground of the
elementary school then I watched this
tiny tiny ring of Sodom through the
telescope the picture you recently see
is more fantastic and like the you can
see even the earth from Southern through
the recent technical development by
Cassini I was very much fascinated by
astronomy and I read many books and see
very what seriously wanted to become
astronomer I read many books but my
enthusiam enthusiasm gradually faded
away when my mother gave a book of
biography of Noguchi hideo now which she
is kind of self educated doctor
he moved United States at age of 23 or
so and hired as a professor in
Rockefeller University and identified
syphilis rots in are the cause of
progressive paralysis unfortunately he
died in Ghana during pursuit of arrow
fever pathogens but I'm very much
impressed his strong spirits and tiring
activities so I went to medical school
in Kyoto there I'm a game very fortunate
to meet or some Hayashi my mentor who
discovered the gas oxygen can be
directly in cope
into organic organic compounds by the
enzyme oxidase he spent nine years in
United States and came back establish
the Department of Biochemistry which is
where I kept it and also he provided
very international atmosphere thanks to
that I had an occasion to discuss with
Jack mano in very early stage in my
career I was also very fortunate that
soon after I went in the graduate course
I picked up the interesting paper by
John career he says Geoff theory toxin
in activates protein synthesis
elongation factor EF - and this reaction
requires respiratory coenzyme nad I was
very much fascinated and tried find out
what's a mechanism of nad I was very
fortunate
Nishioka at that time in higher Isha's
love later she found the protein
sequence he made lots of nad derivatives
with radial label compounds and i found
actually diphtheria toxin is the enzyme
that catalyzes ATP ribosomal transfer -
elongation factor - and this way the
enzyme is inactivated with this very
fortunate start of my career
I'm also very fortunate to meet Donna
Braun in Carnegie Institution wasn't an
embodiment
he is a person who opened my eyes to the
molecular immunology he explained to me
their long history not only immunology
but biology antibody diversity is now on
the table we can now tackle this big
question by modern molecular balance
code technology like reverse
transcriptase the mystery of immune
response around 1970 is very attractive
to everybody the question is how can
animals generate antibodies specific to
almost infinite number of antigens
including artificial chemicals like Karl
Landsteiner he took any compounds on his
shelf conjugated with protein inject
animals and then he could prove animals
can generate antibody against the
chemicals so-called hapten with high
specificity so people thought wow animal
may have endless number of
immunoglobulin genes that's obviously
impossible the structure of antibody
which was originally identified from
during and Sheba subrata Sato but
gradually becoming clear number of
scientists involved Paul Ehrlich also
studied lot and most directory Gerald
Edelman was an importer found antibodies
composed to heavy chain to light chain
they are linked by disulphide bond
Hirshman and a Craig and also put Nam
discovered light chain is composed in a
terminal variable and c-terminal
consumed region and obviously the
variable region is responsible for
antigen recognition and constant region
responsible various activity of antibody
to process the capture of the antigens
so the question is how many regions how
many seasons the dawn gave very
attractive idea of multiple V and market
the C but obviously this is the
hypothesis so I was very fortunate don't
introduce me to fill leaders laboratory
in NIH and he hired me as a postdoc I
moved there and worked very hard and
after few years we reached the
conclusion amino group in light chain
either kappa or lambda has only one at
most a few genes the results ironically
suggests Don's idea is wrong
there must be limited number of the see
region and therefore another indication
is to explain the large number with a
variable region expression animal should
have genetic alteration either somatic
hypermutation or recombination or both
ensure enough four years later
Susumu tonegawa found to generate larger
repertoire of amino
even the four light chain vj4 heavy
chain DJ components we assembled during
differentiation and by combinatorial
mechanism they generate enormous
diversity and he was awarded Nobel Prize
87 I believe meantime I decided to go
back to Japan and got a position in
University of Tokyo there after long
thinking I decided to pick up different
project but still I wanted understand
the immunoglobin diversification as my
serious question instead of continuing
the same series of study using a light
chain I switched to the heavy chain
which has obviously different questions
this is related repeated immunization so
called vaccination so people already
knew
after repeated immunization there are
two interesting of the vision one is the
change of the title affinity to the
antigen and this is due to the somatic
hypermutation the b-cell change the
variable region rather randomly and one
of the highest affinity expressing these
cells selected by antigen and this is
the mechanism of antigen induced high
affinity maturation the Alpha mechanism
is class switching the initial antibody
generated normally IgM but after
repeated injections
IgG become dominant the cloths which is
a change of the concentration rather
than V region and that produce from IgM
to IgA IgG IgE and each has different
function and different location and V
region surprisingly remain constant how
this captain and both are antigen driven
so we decided pick up this question and
we are very fortunate to find to make
class switching big chunk of DNA on the
chromosome deleted to express one
particular C gene from IgM IgG to a you
have to believe the pig DNA in that
intervening segment is grouped out and
this was done with the help of bright
medical student in Korea University tour
kataoka and Achilles missile and we also
determined the order of the CH Dean
along the chromosome which we
hypothesized soon after we came to
Sweden and met unum juror D food
mattias wobble many others who compete
each other for cloning immunoglobin
locus and found almost simultaneously
reached a similar conclusion but still
we have many questions we haven't solved
mechanism for somatic hypermutation and
also most importantly what the enzyme to
mediate such interesting genetic
alteration and we also fortunate to
obtain original sage traversal which can
be stimulated from IGM to IG a with cd40
Lion Heart for tgf-beta and Masamichi
muramatsu came and try to see the
difference between steam rated non
stimulated and they found new gene
called activation in the cited in the
ominous a ID which is specifically
expressed Germany Center b-cells
involved for class switch recombination
probably and we made a knockout and the
knockout animals showed strong induction
of IgM by immunization but IgG showing a
blue is totally absent in air D
deficient animals in addition hyper
mutation is also described in air D
deficient animals and no hyper mutation
as compared heterozygote AI D animals
our collaborator in France and Randy and
the Aaron Fisher also found any human
cohort patient of hyper IGM syndrome
type 2 they all had a mutation the same
gene a ID and we publish the paper on
side by side and together a ID is the
enzyme that engraves antigen memory in
the antibody gene and this is the
mechanistic basis for vaccination so
taken together
Susumu tonegawa showed the repertory
generation by putting vdj together and
mature be so migrate of periphery and
see the pathogen induce a ID and that
mediate hyper mutation
class switching occasionally it is
apparently induced and caused to more
and this is very rare because most of
the immunology thought immune activation
rather suppress tumor growth
the idea of cancer immunotherapy dates
back to the last century but the very
hypothetical backbone of can't I -
therapy immune surveillance was proposed
by Sir Frank MacFarlane Burnet 1970 and
because of this very strong hypothetical
background large number of people try to
demonstrate by activating immune system
tumor can be suppressed or treated and
unfortunately as you heard from Jim it
was very difficult the trial includes
many different types first many people
isolated and purified cancer specific
proteins called no antigens and produced
in abundance injected as a vaccine
another trials in which reactivation of
T lymphocyte using il-2 and putting back
to the same patient also earth injection
of cytokines like interferon gamma L to
L 12 or failure retrospectively all
these trial or to push axial and
unfortunately immune system was totally
under the strong break induced by tumor
growth
to identify the immune system break came
only 1995 when Jim Allison showed C
therefore is kind of the parking brake
paired with city city 28 is ignition
molecule and I think this is a comparing
like parking brake and directs on/off
rather drastic regulation we identify
the PD one and the brake and accelerator
I cause pairing and rather mild smooth
regulation of the immune system the
moment we encounter the PD one was very
fortunate I'm very fortunate or over
so yes Massa Ishida came to my
department what it identified thymus
selection mechanism namely
something involved cell death and here
after he cloned the cDNA by subtraction
and found this surface molecule
hydrophobic regions and intracellular
domain contains highly conserved
tyrosine molecules and to tyrosines a
very well known at that time for
activation signaling molecules but these
two titles in MPD one are different the
distance between two a double compare
the rest of the known activation
molecule so we are convinced there are
something different interesting but I
don't know so we decided to make
knockout and knockout done by Nishimura
and
and that's a beginning of the long
struggle first knockout born rather soon
but couldn't see any phenotypic change
doctor Minato advised to back rows to
the homozygote again no phenotypic
change we could see some over response
to antigen stimulation may be some
negative regulator but not so clear but
it took almost six seven years until we
find clear nephritis of arthritis by
crossing with L clear air pure
background which is autoimmune prong
five weeks after in case of CTL four by
four weeks every single animal died so
this is a very mild and chronic and
clear at immunity in PD one knockout by
only fourteen months so I don't know
whether Nishimura watched every day I
don't think so she left the mice for
months and one day she found this so
anyway we found PD one knockout in blood
mice shows nephritis arthritis white
mouse called the myopathy and crossed
with the odium from background and OD m
ll all accessible very severe phenotype
we are very much convinced this is the
negative regulator because we release
the break immune system goes up Taku
Okazaki photo showed the mechanism by
crossing PD one with T cell receptor
signal induced by antigen recognition it
for three
and pd1 also get phosphated and recruit
phosphatase that D for spoiling one by
one so this way the reaction is reduced
now we find all this mechanism obvious
thing is immune system in balance with
accelerator and brake and no Murray if
it's a balance it's okay if it goes to
the hyper immune activity it's good for
infectious disease treatment and cancer
treatment but risk of autoimmunity so if
we push broke the brake and push the
axle we have a chance to cure the cancer
so we try this the first experiment I
asked yoshikawa is to compare PD one
deficient animal and while animal see
whether Timo can grow differently the
reason I chose this instead of antibody
is because I don't trust the antibody
because there are many antibodies
I trust the genetics so what we found
sorry is here compared the wild-type PD
one deficiency well this is the last
published data but anyway the first
error she showed was convincing and we
think PD one the efficiency or blockade
is good for suppressing tumor growth so
I called dr. Minato and he already
started making antibody against the PDL
1 and also PD one what PD l1 is the best
antibody available and he could clearly
demonstrate antibody blockade also
suppress tumor growth and even prolong
the survival
are you Yoshio I further went on to show
the metastasis of the melanoma injection
into spleen to liver and liver this is
rather normal and this is metastatic
liver and you can si by weight and color
on that pd-1 treated animal shows much
less metastatic liver
so both PD one blockade or PDL one
blockade we can cure the cancer and the
mechanism we still don't know some
people claim tumor Express ligand and we
block here but PDL 1 is expressed
everywhere almost all ABC Express so how
the CTL become suppressed we still don't
know but anyway the key molecule is PD
one and either lion or receptive
blockade can cure the cancer so we
wanted put this into the clinic and we
need lots of money and lots of the
technologies we are very fortunate medal
X found our published patent and
approached us and studied generate anti
PD one human antibody and the product is
LG g4 and point mutation to prevent
antibody dependent sir made it's a
toxicity and name NIMH Oman and this
antibody was approved by FDA
investigation new drug was first to 2006
and then we can start clinical trial
about that time I met a famous scientist
look this guy and you know so this was a
very unfortunate incident and then the
animal clinical trial went on rather
smoothly and the first report was
published 2012 by Susan - partying and
result was amazing this was all spread
all over the world during Journal
Medicine paper came out and Wall Street
Journal and Frankfurt argument all the
from line of first page so basic message
to one all the patient recruited to a
terminal stage patient with solid tumor
big tumor melanoma lung cancer renal
cancer and surprisingly twenty to eight
20 to 30 percent of patient responded
complete or partial on top of that those
who once responded still respond years
the treatment stopped after two years
but still they respond continued to stay
we did our own clinical trial in small
scale in Kyoto in collaboration Gian
ecology Department and patient or
platinum resistant ovarian cancer and
here again if we include stable disease
as a disease control rate at which to
the 40 to 50 percent and among them we
are very much impressed the lady who
responded very quickly and become
completely to Murphy and this lady
even after we stopped the treatment
after one year
remain tumor-free more than four years
and another case more than 3.5 years
tumor free so without treatment this can
last there is very very ideal the most
impressive clinical trial using me
Bowman published 2015 by international
collaboration many European countries
Australia Canada and they showed
comparison of NIMH ovum and chemo
typical chemo dacarbazine it's a random
trial so it's a blind test and patients
who receive new Vaman almost 70%
survived after year and a half on the
other hand chemo treated patient less
than 20% so the it's a drastic
difference the huge number of clinical
trials I don't have time to mention but
because of this the PD one locate
therapy is now approved over dozen type
of cancers even this year cervical
cancer and primary mediastinal large
b-cell lymphoma and as Jim mentioned
striking all highly mutated cancers it
can detect easily by micro satellite or
the deficiency of mismatch repair enzyme
regardless the origin of tumor tissues
this is very very important so taken
together the PD one treatment opinion
treatment brought paradigm shift in
Kansas
first less adverse effects because
normal cells are almost untouched
secondary effective for wide range of
tumors more than thousand clinical
trials are still ongoing thirdly it
shows diabo effects you can stop the
treatment and they can last at least
four to five years why this is so
effective we already heard enormous
amount of investigators sequenced the
cancer genome the published studying
melanoma to breast cancer or thyroid
cancer
all of them accumulate mutations each
spot is one sample so this is a log
scale plot of coding mutation and normal
cell has no mutation so all tumors has
either thousand times or 10,000 times
higher mutation in coding region that
leads to the expression of new antigen
we call new antigen and those new
antigen are different from our original
protein and that is recognized by immune
system so what we learn is this cancer
cell mutate and make the antigen
secondary mutations are so frequent it's
very difficult to pinpoint what is
dominant mutations or what is the
secondary mutation and the cause of this
cancer
sell continuously mutate and you give
the chemo they change and give rise to
resistant clones another drug another
resistant Crohn's and fortunately
lymphocyte can recognize all these
resistant mutants and cannot tap them
this is the big advantage now I told you
very very promising outcome but this is
not the end of the story you know we
have many many problems first of all
clearly only 20 to 30 percent patient
respond so we have to distinguish
responders from non responders how we
can do it one is high mutagenesis in
tumors which i mentioned but this is
also not always most important point is
potency of individuals immunity some
puke when flu virus you get some people
sneeze and that's all others get 48 very
high fever and almost died so enormous
variation among individual and this is
very difficult because it's not just MHC
gene there are hundreds genes involved
in immune power we also have to deal
with improvement of immunotherapy off we
not twenty to thirty percent of free to
eighty to ninety percent and also there
are two aspects one is access severity
of killer t-cell to tumour site
the other is potency of killer cell
function itself I'd like to briefly
mention about the first aspect candy
tomaten my love found the tumor cell
first attacked by resident Kiera T so by
PD one blockade in this stimulation give
the gamma interferon and tumour cell
itself secrete some chemical and this
also leaves activated T's in lymph node
migrate to the tumor site so PT one
blockade takes place to position one in
tumour site where it's number is very
limited but most important is activation
of killer T cell and info node that
activate chemical receptor and also
differentiation and this is very
important process so often surgeon
removes many lymph node surrounding
lymph to more but that's not good idea
you have to keep intact node and he
showed in animal experiment if you
remove draining lymph node even if we
inject anti pd-1 that tumor cannot be
reduced chemo keep growing now as Jim
said now many people trying to combine
with PD one with CTL for and chemo
radiotherapy M bgf a and OPCON
combination so thousand combinatorial
trial going on and we hope there will be
something very promising come out
in a few years we also try new approach
in our case we know that t-lymphocyte 1
get activated needs lots of energy and
lots of compounds energy depends on
mitochondria and so we screened
chemicals which might be able to boost
my country and it may attack the tumor
more efficiently we and others showed
PDC one alpha
code transcription factor coupled with
people signaling activate essential step
in mitochondria activation oxidative
phosphorylation and fatty acid
consumption in fact better fit braids
together with anti PDL one antibody in
animal to model the effect of the
antibody is further enhanced
synergistically
so this is promising so we now on
clinical trial in Japan Kyushu
University and the common water
University and HI we hope the results
relatively soon the mechanism the two
whole one is the base affiliated paper
signaling promote increased
proliferation generation effect a killer
T cells and also they enhance the
proliferation into memory generation
instead of exhaustion and service by
these two mechanism Faysal favorite
combination PD one blockade increase
number of killer T cells
in tumour site so I'd like to add a
little bit about adverse effect of the
PD want efficiency Cydonia fat allison
in reconned
together with the finish Komatsu that
showed pd-1 deficient animal show serum
level reduction of treat for metabolism
and medic mitochondria activation
related compounds so it grows so rapidly
they consume essential amino acid and
madcon you're turning on very rapidly
they can monitor it in serum an actually
this enormous expansion and consumption
metabolites effects even the brain
neurotransmitter level like serotonin
and dopamine and induce behavior change
and she father showed this is related
with gut bacteria change earlier for
essence group showed pd-1 deficiency
reduce high affinity iga production IG
that combined good bacteria in efficient
for symbiosis and they lose such I see a
production and change microbiota
spectrum in the gut less anaerobic
bacteria and increase the enter batter
like e.coli and this will in turn
stimulate host immune system an actually
to make high affinity IgA
you need a ID another my favorite
molecule in German or center-cut
germinal Center PD one on t-cell
interact with PD ligand on bezel and if
b-cell can capture good antigen and
presents strong stimuli to t-cell they
cannot proliferate they can offer the
help to be so produce good antibody so
only P cell which can produce high
affinity iga get this selection by T so
in germinal center and that good for
controlling Guttmacher bacteria in fact
Park mm - Sonia fat Alison showed first
time air D deficiency skewed gut
microbiota and expand on segmented favor
v filamentous bacteria like this and
this caused enormous expansion of the
power patch on the gut and even the
spleen is enlarged so gut microbiota is
very critical to control the level of
the host immune system so we ask the
question
PD one deficiency definitely have hyper
team activity how about air d deficiency
the result just like pd-1 deficiency air
d deficiency has strong anti-tumor
activity even without pd-1 blockade this
is just straight animal and this
separation of tumor grows in air d
deficient
is bhakti or dependent because in
jam-free condition they don't show any
difference so what's happening is pd-1
and ard should collaborate to produce
appropriate IgA to control gut
microbiota and this balance is important
to maintain in intolerance and
homeostatic balance of metabolome
improbably brain condition but once this
balance is destroyed either pd-1
deficiency or AI D deficiency they
cannot produce appropriate IgA to
control micro biota and it may enhance
the anti-tumor activity but on the other
side they cause some emotional or
behavioral defect and also Ottoman
diseases so we clearly don't know much
about the whole body regulation and we
have to learn more and more 2016 Anna :
quote it don't chain saying we just
discovered cancer equivalent penicillin
although the penicillin itself couldn't
cure all infections it gave rise the
whole generation of antibiotics that
change the medicine forever
consigning most previously fatal
infections to history so I hope this
will be true
currently the still immunotherapy is
minor fraction of the cancer treatment
but because of enormous efforts of
number of the people it will eventually
grow and more and more cancers may be
treated by immunotherapy and someday I
don't know whether it's a 2030 or not
cancer may not completely disappear but
be controlled by immunotherapy cancer
may become one of the chronic diseases
if you still have a tumor but no growth
that's okay especially for elderly
people
you can keep your quality of life now
last century we eradicated infectious
disease by vaccination and antibiotics
and this century
I hope cancer we control by
immunotherapy it's an improvement
including as I mentioned microbiome
manipulation had said at the beginning
our quail immunity is critical a quite
amenity evolved in vertebrates as a
defense system against the pathogens
consequently the lifespan of the
vertebrates expanded dramatically that's
why we are here
fortunately cancer cells are key married
mutations and Express new antigens which
can also be recognized by acquired
immunity so this must be the bonus of
evolution
finally I like to thank my collaborators
I cannot mention all of the people
involved some people
well I think it's too much because there
are more people than I could list
I leave the so long
so I I oh so many people and this is the
also the list of the funding agency who
support me for a long term well thank
you for your attention
[Applause]
[Music]
the 2018 Nobel lectures in Physiology or
medicine have now come to an end we
would like to extend our gratitude to
the Nobel laureates for their extensive
presentations thank you all for
attending and thank you for sharing this
significant moment with us when you
leave the hall please leave the same way
you came in now there is an opportunity
to photograph the Nobel laureates on
stage may I ask the laureates
on to the stage for a round of applause
[Applause]